let's get into like the sticky
and talk about vaccines oh we're gonna
go there we have to go there I do I do
try to avoid topics that are like you
know the Hot Topic because there's
there's persecution you know like like
one of the things I want to talk about
is like the the burning of witches and
it's like no this this is still the
burning of witches here and you know one
of my colleagues and good friends in the
medical field is Dr Robert Sears he has
released a book called The vaccine book
he has a client base where when he
started the majority of his clients were
questioning some you know vaccine
choices as his practice evolved
everybody kind of saw him as the the
pediatrician that would accept them you
know a lot of Pediatricians if they're
controlled by the insurance companies
will say hey we can't see you in our
office like you need to find another
pediatrician